what's up everyone welcome back for
another comic-con 2022 interview with
one of my favorite human beings on this
planet
the series campbell the seagulls are
here
they're cat-calling i like animals but i
did say human being oh human being actor
producer
you know how awesome i think you are
congratulations it's a pleasure to be
here because it's nice to i never
thought i would miss all of these
people
yes you would i do you are a con pro
though but i miss i actually miss my
green room buddies
because there's a lot of actors i only
see at conventions it's the only time
that i can torment shatner
who do you look forward to seeing most
in those green rooms when you come to
these oh shatner's awesome but shatner
it's like 30 seconds and then leave him
alone he's going to go back to tweeting
you know so i come up i kiss his butt a
little bit kiss his ring and then it's
fade off and so he's always he's happy
to see me because he knows i'm not going
to be there long that seems like a
really respectable approach when
everybody is overrun at these cons i get
it and elvira cassandra she's she's
incredibly sweet she's always making
like green tea off to the side and stan
lee was he was a very jolly guy sort of
the cliche stan lee
uh he was either that or he was sleeping
in a chair
and if you're 90 408 you get to do that
you get to associate with some of the
coolest most talented people here i love
it i love it so we are here right now
celebrating the at-home release of
doctor strange in the multiverse of
manchester united tuesday tuesday we
gotta talk a whole lot about pizza papa
right now but first
more broadly with your marvel experience
what is something about the process of
making a marvel movie that has stayed
the same from spider-man until doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness but
then what's something about the process
nowadays that made you go like whoa i
can't believe that they do that now to
make these movies a marvel movie is
always it's tricky if you're in them
because you never know if you're going
to still be in them like if i was
benedict cumberbatch
i'd be nervous that i was going to be
cut out of doctor strange
because they shoot it's a big storyline
it's really a mini-series
all of these movies it's not they're not
individual movies
because i was talking about there's a
lot of exposition in doctor strange and
i mentioned that to someone and they go
i needed every bit of it
and i never thought of it that way
because i didn't
know the 14 other movies the chronology
so i see how important it is to people
so people really i mean the fans of
these marvel movies it's an army
of people
if i tweet anything associated like i
should just wake up in the morning and
go
marvel and like would picture myself and
just
people they go crazy you totally could
do because there's so many fans though
of marvel you know as opposed to like
you know the evil dead movies have a
good low
strong pulse of a fandom but you know
they're small and humble
marvel is like it's a it's massive it's
amazing they've really sustained it too
for 20 years now since spidey it is
really general spider-man it's it's a
stunning run it is really really
incredible it blows my mind to think how
they built this it has made careers and
ended careers
and stagnated careers has it really hell
yeah who do you who comes to mind i'm
not gonna tell you i'm not gonna rat
anybody out but big movies you get so
imprinted like you know
the hemsworth boys
you know
if you play thor
like three or four times you gotta be
careful
like you're gonna have to do a serial
killer movie next well you know what i
mean you're gonna have to be do a really
unique netflix movie after where he got
to balance like
his comedic chops but with also like
this sinister element to it also and it
was very effective good that'll help i
do feel like a lot of the big marvel
stars in particular though have done an
exceptional job and this is because they
are like pure talent all on their own an
exceptional job doing the marvel movies
but also showing off all the other
assets they have well you just proved me
wrong so i'll just shut the hell up
let's move on to pizza papa in
particular right now sure somewhat
similar question for you on that what is
the biggest difference between the pizza
papa sam first pitch to you compared to
what we see in the final movie it always
changes with sam because whatever is on
the written page doesn't really hold
water when you actually go to shoot
because he'll see it and then he'll go
okay all right yeah you're not going to
say that anymore you know let's let's
try that say this it's very fluid which
is great it's a great way to work
because some writers are really
foclimped
and they like don't change a word
and some writers are really really
uptight and some directors are nervous
that they'll get yelled at if you want
to fool around a little bit
sam throws it all out the window when
you show up to work was it always pizza
papa and pizza balls or did that idea
ever i think he was always some street
vendor type dude i was in it i was out i
was in i was out i mean i think i was in
and out of it three or four times
according to the editor what about
actually i'm going to apply that
question now to sam's process in general
because i know you guys like to play
around on all your movies so what is it
what is something about his process that
stayed the same from your first
collaboration until now and then what's
something you saw him do on doctor
strange that made you go even though
i've known you for so long i didn't know
you were capable of that well sam is
just uh
he's a technically literate director
like he read
the american cinematographer's manual
and
no nobody reads that crap i mean that's
if i want to you know hang myself i'll
read stuff like that aperture settings
and and frame rates and exposures and
all that
because if you he sort of looked at it
like a magician so what are the tools
that i have of this camera here like
what can that
canon camera do
and i think
we would all know about 10 of what that
camera can do sam would learn 100 of
what that camera can do and he would
he'd make it roll over and bark we i
finished
we did uh army of darkness
and we had a scene
where
it was not in the finished movie i had
to hit like 12 different marks on the
floor without looking at them and the
camera was doing crazy readjustments
every everywhere i went and at the very
end it ended on an extreme close-up of
my ear
and i thought i was taking pity on
myself like god man i'm really i'm
working it man i'm really earning my pay
and i look over at the guy who's pulling
focus he was pouring
pouring sweat because he goes
this movie is is killing me he goes
every trick i've ever learned on any
shoot i've had to use in like the last
three weeks on this movie because of how
demanding sam is and it has to work i
mean that that was one uncut
fluid shot it had it had to work it had
to be in focus and this guy hamid i mean
he was trembling i saw him out of the
corner of my eye i mean he was like
twitching trying to make sure that final
close-up worked it's so that's how he
works he's very demanding
but he's a blast to watch
and it's so awesome
to trash talk back to a big hollywood
director now the crew like in england we
shot we shot in london you know the
english cruise
very popular the english cruise so i
show up stamp starts being mean to me
right away
so i start dishing it back and the crew
members are like
whoa who's this day player who's like
getting in this director's face oh they
were stunned for like the whole day and
then i'm gone
it's great sam's ability to do all that
digging and understand the camera though
is definitely a big part of the reason
why his style is so distinct like i
don't need to see his name in the
credits but if i see his footage i know
it's good
i will say this it's not just this you
know what i mean cameras shooting up
your nose going in circles
watch watch two movies
without the sound
watch evil dead two
and a simple plan
so a simple plan sam's not a
masturbatory filmmaker because the
simple plan how he shot it he'd have
whole conversations with one angle just
bill paxton bridget found it just
talking it's a simple
plan it's a simple movie and then as the
movie gets crazier then he starts to
dial it up a little bit he matches his
style to the material
other filmmakers who i will not name are
look at me
look at me i'm a filmmaker
tell the story
so sam will go crazy with the camera if
it calls for it so if you're doing yeah
if you're doing this movie go nuts this
is why sam is one of my favorites
what you just described is literally a
project i did in film school comparing
the evil ted movies to a simple plan and
i studied that movie more than i care to
admit right now
let's talk a little bit i don't know if
i've over thought this about the pizza
papa backstory did you ever come up with
the reason why he decided like my
business my thing should be pizza balls
i can't talk about a lot of it
but
if you think he's just the pizza guy
you are so gravely mistaken
it's a character
that this special interloper he's an
interloper
between universes
there was a reason why he delayed
doctor strange for about 45 seconds did
he not
he delayed him
he did not go further down the street
you can put into it whatever you want i
know for a fact he saved dr strange's
life
for a reason so he's put there for a
reason and it's not because he's a pizza
vendor he's not just gonna be what i
call p squared okay
i really would believe that this is the
beginning
this is not the end of pizza papa
i genuinely want it to be the beginning
but every every single time you're in a
marvel movie it's a marvel movie that
sam is directing does that mean you are
leaving marvel doesn't really like me
that much but if sam says i i need to
use campbell they won't get in the way
but what if it's another director would
you when marvel would go we don't need
campbell that badly
the marvel doesn't know what they're
doing and i have to erase this whole
conversation i would never accuse marvel
of not knowing what they're doing
hopefully the sarcasm came during that
comment yeah really now i'm screwed i
will never survive after this interview
i'm still very hung up on pizza balls
though in general how do you feel about
pizza balls because i'm a new yorker so
i have very specific taste in my pizza
they probably suck yeah that's kind of
what i'm thinking but didn't want to say
it but look you know your friend
is down the hallway in a hotel room you
roll a few down to them
you know it's not a bad delivery method
all right i guess that is a pro of a
pizza ball yeah but not much else did
you ever consider what your character
might be doing in different universes do
you think he's a food vendor with a
different food in every single universe
it has nothing to do with him his job my
role in the multiverse is way beyond
being a pizza vendor i mean you're only
going to realize this like when i talk
to you again in five years
mine your mind will be blown at what
they do with what was formerly known as
the pizza papa i'm going to start with
that i'm formerly known as pizza pop
i'll believe it and this is truly a big
reason why i love marvel is because as
the series progresses then i go back and
i watch their earlier films and certain
things have had added layers because of
what i know that they led to right
case in point pizza papa
i'll believe it i'll believe it all
right i have to ask you a little bit
about evil dead in particular
just like ash versus evil dead i don't
think i'll ever get over the
cancellation of that show but now that
we are you know some years removed from
that are you able to share anything at
all about what the plan for season four
was because that was an a plus
cliffhanger well and we didn't design it
to be a cliffhanger we knew the ratings
were bad after the end of the second
season we just we knew it uh no one knew
what stars was
i would say hey we're making evil as a
tv show people would go yeah
where can i see it stars
and then it would be a pause
and a pause and then they would go what
stars
when it dropped on netflix people went
hey
cool
cool netflix is finally doing the evil
dead show i'm like oh my god it was
three three years too late so it's okay
it's commerce it's business you know
these
companies were all expanding amc led the
way we're not just going to show other
people's movies we're going to make our
own original stuff so everyone is making
their own original stuff stars used to
just show
other people's movies
so the new
the new sort of paradigm is no you own
it it's going to cost you a lot of money
but now you own these properties so
starters tried to do the same thing
but no one knew who they were is there
any hope in your mind and sand mines
whatsoever for the continuation of as an
animated uh series you pick up right
where the show left off okay you can do
the future a lot easier in animation
that's fair you know and i still sound
like ash and i you know my voice doesn't
have you know
my voice hasn't been as beat up as my
body has been so i can still do that
crap so i'll still do the video game
and we're already talking about animated
i have all the faith in the world if
there was more live action ash you would
still kick ass no i've i hang up this i
know i know no it's official you have
earned the right you have given us quite
a bit we left it on the table let's look
people always go
you know we needed evil did four
instead you got 15 hours
of un completely it's the most unrated
television show made in the history of
television i mean my head goes up a
cadaver's butt
that's cheered in my brain for life stop
that i mean that's you can't get that
out of your head so it the fans did get
the mother lode and they're enjoying it
now because they're just now finding it
and i'm like fine doesn't matter so i
don't want to be
like i want to be greedy and get more
ash versus evil dead but we are also
getting evil dead rise which is very
exciting it is because it actually does
not suck in the least i would no i would
believe lee cronin did a great job he's
exceptional sam picks these
these these director types who've had
some experience
but we can still sort of shove them into
the evil dead box a little bit because
these are maverick type directors lee's
work is very different from sam's and
from the style of the other evil dead
movies so i give sam credit he's not
picking people who are just going to
mimic his [ __ ] they come with very
strong personalities and approaches and
lee did a very it's a very european evil
dead
how so just his sensibility the whole
thing about it i don't think there's a
handheld shot in the entire movie
okay
from his previous work i could picture
that picture that's very methodical
very methodical what about the high-rise
setting because that's a very unusual
thing
the apartment is the cabin and it's a
single mom it's not ash there's no
connection to the previous movie at all
these days it's about that darn book
where does that darn book show up
because there's three of them after all
we learned that from army of darkness
there's one in my apartment actually
well there there's a lot of them out
there but there's three three books so
it's really about that these days which
is nice because we don't have to tie it
in it's too much brain power to have to
connect all the dots to all these movies
so they they kind of they're going to
operate on their own now so you're not
in that movie you are executive
producing you do have one line of
dialogue in the movie you do i play a
priest you'll hear me on a i would
expect you'll hear me on a an old record
that okay that is being played back over
the speakers yeah do any of the new
characters have any ash qualities no
none at all none there's no
there's only one
one one male person in the movie
everyone else is female well ladies can
have kick-ass ash qualities too oh they
do i watched dana do it the entire time
during um
so our heroine we have a heroine in this
case and yeah she kicks ass okay i like
it i'll end with this one for you
because i love looking into the
evolution of horror throughout the years
what is the best recent horror movie you
have seen and why do you love it so much
you'd have to you'd actually have to
list a few because i
i don't i actually don't go out of my
way to look at horror like i'll watch
lawrence walk before i watch a horror
movie i could tell you some of my
favorite from this year sure the new
scream movie okay didn't see it oh man
what about x have you seen ty west's i
didn't see it all right
this one's upcoming your body's body's
bodies is great too never heard of it a
lot of great twenty-four i'm so out of
it i am out of it out of it you're
you're allowed to be out of it because
you've given us so much in the genre and
i'm so greatly appreciated appreciative
of it and i am appreciative of your time
today just to remind everyone here even
though i could talk evil dead all day
long we are here to celebrate doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
which you can buy on digital right now
tuesday it's going to be availa
digital's now actually okay like i said
now arcade blu-ray and dvd is
tuesday fantastic thank you so much for
your time bruce thank you all for
watching we'll see you soon with more
comic-con interviews
you